Hallo, Guten Tag, meine Name ist Demirel und ich bin der Lisabendas und ich bin heute für Sie zuständig.
Ja.
Ja, kurz zum Ablauf, ich werde Ihnen eine Frage zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt zu Ihren Bechwerten begegen.
Ja, klar.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Franz Meister.
Franz Meister.
Mhm.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vorname bestellen?
Ja, der Vorname ist Franz.
Ja.
Und der Familienname ist S-T-E-R.
Ja, okay.
Und wie alt sind Sie, Herr Meister?
Ich bin 67 Jahre alt.
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Am 17., 6., 54.
74.
54.
Ja, Herr Meister, was führt das uns, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also, eigentlich ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich so viel Gewicht abgenommen habe.
Und das macht mir eigentlich so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Aber in den letzten drei Monaten habe ich 7 kg abgenommen.
Das kann auch nicht normal sein.
Okay, wie viel wiegen Sie derseits?
Ja, ich wiege 74 kg noch.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,76 m.
Ja, und tatsächlich fühle ich mich auch irgendwie nicht so richtig gut.
Ich bin immer so müde und fühle mich ein bisschen schlapp.
Und nachts kann ich auch nicht gut schlafen.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit verändert? Haben Sie Petitlosigkeit?
Nein, eigentlich habe ich das Gefühl, ich esse ganz gut.
Deswegen wundere ich mich ja so, dass ich es so abgenommen habe.
Okay.
Ich habe es halt ein bisschen mit der Prostatei. Das ist wohl bekannt.
Also ich muss nachts immer auf die Toilette.
Und zurzeit muss ich auch ziemlich oft gehen.
Ja nachts, nachts eben, das, was ich muss ich dreimal aufstehen.
Das schläft man natürlich nicht so besonders gut.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Hab sie Herzrasen?
Herzrasen? Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe so ein bisschen Husten.
Also das hat der Arzt mal gesagt, dass das so eine chronische Lungenerkrankung ist.
Ja, ich habe ja...
Ich habe schon lange, ich habe natürlich auch schon viele Jahre gerauft.
Schon seit ich 17 bin raufig.
Seit 17. Ja, ja.
Auch wenn Sie seit 50 Jahren.
Ja, ja, aber jetzt ja nicht gerade exzessiv, aber halbens Päckchen am Tag rauf ich wohl schon, ja.
Haben Sie viel mehr Mehl geraucht oder?
Eigentlich immer so ein bisschen mäßig eigentlich, ja.
Ich habe noch keine Becher.
Der ist, würde ich sagen, eher trocken.
Hab ich nicht.
Ich habe noch keine Becher.
Ja, sonst keine, wie gesagt, diese Müdigkeit und halt, dass ich ständig auf die Toilette muss.
Okay, hab ich das Problem beim Massele, also mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ja, das habe ich ja gerade gesagt, dass ich immer auf die Toilette muss.
Das Stuhlgang ist eigentlich normal, ja.
Ja, arbeiten Sie derseits?
Nein, ich bin Rentner zum Glück.
Was war Ihr Beruf?
Ich war KFC Mechaniker, also Automechaniker.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, dass Sie das
15 Jahre schon lange haben.
Und mit der Prostata, das hat auch schon, ja, bestimmt schon 7, 8 Jahre.
Der Arzt hat immer gesagt, die ist ein bisschen vergrößert.
Ja, und nehmen Sie gegen Syrupid mit Kamenta ein?
Ja, ich habe das so ein Spree, aber wie das heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Okay, neben das Autoclite?
Ja, für die Prostata nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und abends, aber wie die heißt, das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Ich habe die jetzt auch nicht mitgenommen.
Okay, Sie haben jetzt keine Medikamentale dabei?
Nein, ich habe kein Zettel dabei.
Okay, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Mein Hausarzt ist Dr. Müller.
Wir können die Information von Dr. Müller sagen.
Ja, okay.
Und leider ist es an einer Krankheit, an einer krankischen Krankheit.
Und leider ist es noch an einer anderen Krankheit.
Nein, sonst habe ich ja zugeblieben.
Und dann haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, wenn ich so überlege, ich bin noch nie operiert worden.
Ja, guck mal, bin ich ja ganz schön alt geworden.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie allergierig, dann regen Sie auf bestimmte Medikamente allergierig.
Das ist mir bisher noch nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe aber auch noch nicht so viel genommen bisher.
Aber allegien sind bei mir nicht bekannt.
Sind Sie vollgegengst?
Ja, diese Corona-Geschichte, da bin ich geimpft.
Ja, ja.
Und gegen die Kinderkrankheiten?
Gegen die anderen Krankheiten, ja.
Ich glaube schon, dass ich alles habe, was man so braucht.
Ja, sehr gut.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit in einem Auslands?
Nein, zurzeit, nein, ich bin nicht verreist in letzter Zeit, gar nicht.
Okay, Herr Meister, ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Sie sind verheiratet.
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich erwachsen, ne?
Ja, genau.
Lebe Sie mit Ihren Ehemanns, oder?
Ja, ich wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen, ja, ja.
Ja, in einer Wohnung, oder?
Ja, ja.
Herr Meister, ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie seit 50 Jahren rauchen.
Sie trinken auch Alkohol?
Ja, hin und wieder mal bei einem Fest, oder wenn man eingeladen ist,
oder ja, an Weihnachten oder so, ja, dann trinkt man mal ein bisschen Alkohol,
aber nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, was trinken Sie?
Ja, mal Bier oder mal ein Schluch Sekt, ja.
Und einmal proche ungefähr oder mehr oder weniger?
Nein, ach weniger, weniger.
Herr Meister, nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine routine Frage.
Aber Sie haben bisher mit Drogen Kontakt gehabt.
Ja, mit einem Alter, nein, mit Drogen habe ich nichts am Hut, nein.
Ja, bleiben Sie schon regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, also ich fahre wohl hin und wieder mit dem Fahrrad noch,
aber so richtig Sport mache ich eigentlich nicht, nein.
Aber ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie.
Hat jemand in Ihrer Familie Krönchenkrankheiten oder Vorerkrankheiten?
Ja, ich nehme an, dass Sie da nicht mehr am Leben sind.
Meine Mutter lebt tatsächlich noch, die ist hochgetagt, die ist also über 90,
aber naja, die ist natürlich nicht mehr ganz gesund,
aber sie ist noch am Leben und mein Vater ist vor einigen Jahren gestorben,
der hatte tatsächlich Darmkrebs.
Aber sonst wüsste ich nicht, dass die irgendwelche so langwierigen Erkrankungen hatten.
Ist Irfa da an Darmkrebs gestorben oder?
Der ist an Darmkrebs gestorben, ja.
Aber es ist nicht so.
Ja, ich habe einen jüngeren Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Der ist gesund, ja.
Okay, Herr Meister, Sie rübsch, ihr seid wieder bei uns.
Ja, ich möchte kurz Ihre Bechwerte zusammenfassen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie in der letzten drei Monaten
ungefähr 7 kg abgenögen sind.
Abgenögen haben.
Ja.
Sie leiden unter Müdigkeit und Durchlaufprobleme.
Ja, weil ich immer auf die Toilette muss, deswegen kann ich nicht sagen.
Ja, haben Sie auch Nachtschuhe?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, okay, sehr.
Ihr Appetit ist gut.
Ja, ich ja.
Ja, deswegen wundere ich mich ja, dass ich abgenommen habe.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich oder möchten Sie etwas erinnern?
Ja, woran kann denn das jetzt liegen, dass ich so abgenommen habe?
Ja, die Hosen sploddern und ja, das ist ja nicht gesund,
wenn man mit einmal so viel abnimmt und man ist eigentlich gut.
Ja, es ist gut, dass Ihr Appetit gut ist.
Und ja, Sie haben keine Haare, keine standen Hände.
Ich habe nicht aufgefallen, dass Ihr Haare aufgefallen sind.
Haare ausgefallen?
Ja.
Ja, gut, in meinem Alter hat man nicht mehr so viele Haare als man war.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber dass die jetzt extrem ausgefallen sind, kann ich nicht sagen, nein.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie ansonsten keine Beschwerde?
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Sonst wüsste ich nicht, dass ich noch irgendwelche Beschwerden habe, ne?
Okay, haben Sie, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihr Angeschulden und Hälfte konnten?
Geschwollende Lymphknoten, da wüsste ich gar nicht, wo ich die suchen muss, nein, keine Ahnung.
Ja, am Hals oder unter dem Arm?
Das habe ich nie nachgeguckt, müssen Sie nachher mal bei der Untersuchung gucken, ja.
Okay.
Wann waren Sie das letzte Mal bei einem Arzt?
Ja, bei meinem Hausarzt.
Da ist bestimmt schon zwei Jahre her, ja, ein, zwei Jahre her.
Ja, außer Prost Fabrius und Sophie, die sind, waren Sie gesund.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, okay.
Herr Meister, eigentlich möchte ich erst Sie per Pelig untersuchen, ein paar und Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ja.
Und noch ein paar, gegen den Fest, möchte ich ein paar Bildgewendesterfahren durschüren.
Ja, was ist denn ein bildgebendes Verfahren?
Ich möchte Sie röntgen schicken, zum röntgen schicken, um Ihre Lünge zu untersuchen und Ihre Bauch.
Ja, und ein paar Ultraschall-Untersuchungen durschüren.
Ja.
Je nachdem, wie fünder möchte ich, können wir noch ein paar Untersuchungen durschüren.
Ja, und ich natürlich möchte ich so erst Ihre Vitalkarometer prüfen.
Ja, dann können wir genau besprechen.
Ja, das ist okay.
Gut.
Ja.
Hat jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen?
Ob ich Rückenschmerzen habe?
Wir haben uns eigentlich nicht.
Hätten Sie schon bemerkt, dass Sie so Stolgankfarbe veranderen, die letzte Zeit?
Ach so, das hat ja nicht gemerkt, nein.
Gut, mögen Sie schon den Patienten vorstellen?
Oder brauchen Sie noch einen Moment?
Dr. Demirel.
Ja, wir können anfangen.
Wir können anfangen, okay, gut.
Ja, guten Tag Frau Wersten.
Ja, guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patenten aufgenommen und möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, sehr patient hat Franz Meister, 7, 8, 7, 80 Jahre alt, gebühren am Zöchten erst in 1954.
1 Meter 76, 1 Meter 70 und er wiegt derzeit 4,70 Kilogramm.
Er ist verheiratet und verrentet der KFC Mechaniker und lebt mit ihnen froh in einer Wohnung.
Mit seiner Frau?
Ja.
Der Patient stellte sich heute bei uns wegen der Gehübsabnahme in der letzten 3 Monaten von 7 Kilogramm.
Oh ja.
Er berichtet, dass er in der letzten Zeit auch Müdigkeit hat.
Und Schlafprobleme hat, in Somnia hat.
Er hat auch recht lange trockenen Ostern.
Aber er leidet an COPD seit 4 Jahren.
Er leidet auch an prostatiparpilasi seit ungefähr 7 bis 8 Jahren.
Er nimmt gegen COPD ein Cypher, aber der Name des Cypher weiß, der patente nicht.
Er nimmt gegen prostatiparpilasi ein Medikamente einmal am Morgen.
Und der Name des Medikaments weiß der Patente auch nicht.
Der Hausarzt des Patents, Patientin Dr. Müller.
Und der Ostern nimmt keine regelmäßige Medikamente.
Er hat keine Allergie.
Er braucht seit 50 Jahren ein halbes Paket Patient-Potat.
Er trink selten Alkohol.
Er trinkst die Mutter des Patienten.
Er trinkt die Mutter des Patienten.
Aufgrund der Analympie-Angaben gehe ich von einem Verdach auf.
Lossemi aus.
Blokemi?
Ja, Lossemi aus.
Und ja.
Was wäre zifferenzial Diagnostisch noch möglich?
Was für eine Idee gäbe es noch?
Ja, als Differenz sehr dirkundes Gönn und Pläforma und vielleicht ein Tüberkühler
in Betracht.
Aber der Patient hat keine Nachschweiß.
Keine Figur.
Ja.
Aber warum schläft er denn nicht?
Ja, er hat seit ungefähr acht Jahren Prostate per Pläsi und in der Nacht
muss er oft auf die Qualität gehen.
Ja, wie ist der Parkbegriff?
Nekturi.
Ja, genau.
Hat er sonst über Beschwerden mit der Prostata geklagt?
Nein, bitte, ich habe nicht gehört.
Hat er über Beschwerden hinsichtlich der Prostata geklagt?
Hat er da etwas dazu gesagt?
Ja, so.
Nein.
Hat nichts gesagt?
Okay, ich habe nicht viel erhebbar.
Nein, nein, also ich habe die Frage haben Sie nicht verstanden.
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Ich habe gefragt, hat der Patient über Beschwerden hinsichtlich der
Prostata geklagt?
Hat er da irgendwas beschrieben, dass ihm das Beschwerden macht?
Ich sehe mich daran nicht.
Okay, gut.
Ja, was machen Sie denn jetzt mit der, von der Untersuchung her?
Wo setzen Sie an?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich zuerst den Patienten förbärlich untersuchen.
Worauf, akzeptieren Sie besonders?
Ja, alle Systeme möchte ich untersuchen.
Lunge Abdomen möchte ich, lunge Herz und Abhörden und Abdomen auch
abhörden und palpieren.
Und dann Patienten Blut abnehmen.
Worauf lassen Sie das Blut untersuchen?
Ja, ich möchte großes Blutbild und ein Sundungsparameter,
Leberparameter, Leberwerte, Niesenwerte, Apfeli.
Und ich möchte ein, Leberwerte und Niesenwerte.
Ja, und worauf, was sollte man sicherlich auch noch untersuchen,
bei dem?
Im Blut, oder?
Mhm.
Ja.
Denken Sie mal an seine Prostata.
Ja, wegen, es kann auch Prostata sein, vielleicht.
Mhm.
Ja, also, woran popen wir im Labor?
Ja, Prostatspezifikatigen.
Genau, PSA-Wert, genau.
Ja, gut.
Und ja, im Rahmen der Untersuchung, was würden Sie da unter Umständen
relativ zügig machen können?
Ja, ich möchte ein paar Lungen untersuchen.
Ja, was machen Sie noch bei der, sage ich mal,
körperlichen und orientierenden Untersuchung?
Was würde man sicherlich aufmachen müssen?
Ja, ich möchte rektal, rektal, palkpastion.
Ja, genau.
Gucken, ob da die Prostata verherrte zu spüren ist.
Genau, sehr gut.
Okay.
Und ja, dann haben Sie gesagt, Sie wollen apparativ noch weiter
und wollen, was wollen Sie da machen?
Also Sie haben Röntgen, ich habe nicht alles behalten,
Röntgen wollen Sie, ne?
Ja, Toddachs und Abdomen, ja, bei des Optomethologen
auch durchschnittlich.
Optomet auch alle Fälle gucken, ja?
Ja.
Und beim Röntgen, worauf gucken Sie da?
Ja, beim Röntgen, ich meinte Toddachs und Abdomen
Röntgen in zwei Ebenen, aber ich will können auch
Lombär-Röntgen auch durchführen, ob ein Metestas gibt.
Sehr gut, ja, ganz genau.
Sehr schön.
Okay, gut.
Ja, wenn sich jetzt die Untersuchung dahingehend bestätigt,
dass dieser Patient tatsächlich ein Frustrataproblem hat, ja?
Was, so im Sinne eines Karzinoms, ja?
Was wäre dann die erforderliche Therapie?
Ja, erst müssen wir prüfen, ob es ein Metestas gibt.
Eine Metastase oder eine Metastasierung, ja?
Ja, eine Operation und eine Handlung von der OP-Konvention.
Genau.
Von der OP-Konvention.
Und dann, um das zu sehen,
ich will jetzt noch ein bisschen...
Noch ein bisschen?
Ich will jetzt noch ein bisschen Prostataproblem,
aber ich werde es nicht mehr...
Also ich habe nur generell das Thema Chemotherapie, habe ich hier noch stehen.
Ja, Chemotherapie.
Also Prostatomie und Chemo.
Was fällt Ihnen noch ein an diagnostischem Verfahren zur Verifizierung dieses Prostatakazinoms?
Fällt Ihnen dazu noch etwas ein?
Bevor man die Prostatektomie macht, macht man ja erst welche Untersuchungen?
Biopsy vielleicht?
Genau, die Stanz.
Eine Stanzbiopsy im Vorfeld, um da Auszählgewebe zu gucken, ob das wirklich pfysartig wird.
Ja, also ich habe sie jetzt ein bisschen dahin geführt.
Es war tatsächlich das Prostatakazinom bei diesem Patienten hier.
Das ist natürlich mir Gemeinheit, wenn der erzählt, er hat eine benigene Prostatehyperplasie.
Aber das ist ja nun auch bekannt, dass sowas auch entarten kann.
Und dass diese gutartige Form irgendwann umschlägt.
Und der Patient selber war ja auch nicht so wahnsinnig sorgfältig.
Der ist ja nicht lange zum Arzt gegangen.
Aber immerhin, als er jetzt sein Gewicht verloren hat, hat er gemerkt, irgendwas stimmt nicht.
Und tatsächlich hat er aber mehrfach sich beschwert, dass er Probleme beim Wasser lassen hat.
Und dass er ständig, dass das immer so kleine Mengen sind und dass er ständig laufen muss.
Also er hat durchaus das geschildert.
Das haben sie aber irgendwie, wollten sie das nicht so richtig hören.
Ja, okay.
Gut, ja, ich habe ein bisschen Probleme gehabt, am Anfang sie gut zu verstehen.
Nach einer Weile habe ich mich ganz gut eingehört.
Da ist mir das nicht mehr so schwer gefallen.
Ich überlege gerade, ob mir noch sonst irgendwas aufgefallen ist.
Also sagen wir so, der Patient war jetzt nicht so sehr kooperativ.
Das war ein bisschen schwierig mit dem.
Und ja, manchmal hatte er ein bisschen Probleme auch tatsächlich, sie akustisch zu verstehen.
Präsentation fand ich eigentlich schön.
Und ja, dass sie, ich denke mal, das ist sowas, was im Verlauf immer passieren kann, dass man ja nicht die Diagnose jetzt,
dass man da nicht auf richtige Pferd setzt.
Wie gesagt, der hat ja tatsächlich nicht so richtig signifikante Sachen gesagt.
Und eigentlich war der einzige Hinweis, dass das mit der Prostata was sein kann, diese bekannte Hyperplasie.
Gut, gibt es von den Kollegen dazu jetzt noch irgendwelche Fragen oder Kommentare?
Will noch jemand was dazu?